good evening everyone my name is Bill
grew scanned I'm the academic dean at
the Columbia Graduate School of
Journalism and I'm glad to welcome you
here to this event tonight at the
italian academy a little over 10 years
ago shortly after the September 11th
attacks many western journalists flocked
to Afghanistan to learn more about the
breeding ground for the terrorists who
would so transformed our world that day
those journalists who were packing Swiss
Army knives water purification tablets
and satellite phones most of them also
carried a copy of Ahmed rasheed's recent
book and seminal book Taliban that book
sold more than one and a half million
copies worldwide an astonishing number
given the subject in the tone I happen
to reread it over the weekend and it's
really amazing how well Taliban holds up
even though it was written before the
attacks on this country in prose that is
both compelling and insightful Ahmed
explained the military and political
strategy of the Taliban and set a
foundation to help Westerners like many
of us here tonight to understand the
complex and frightening ways of the
movement the xenophobia the constant
demeaning of women the dependence on the
heroin trade and most of all the living
hell it created for the Afghan people it
is us understandable why Christopher
Hitchens once called Ahmed Pakistan's
best and bravest journalist because his
courage has been as essential as his
intelligence in bringing the story to a
larger audience Ahmed is a Cambridge
University graduate who witnessed the
Soviet invasion Afghanistan in the late
1970s he was the first foreign
journalists to interview the Taliban in
1994 and he was in Kabul when the
Taliban over and that city a few years
later throughout the invasion and beyond
his reporting in the far eastern
economic review the independent and many
other publications helped bring to light
the devastation in a corner of the world
the few of us really understood we've
been fortunate to welcome Rashid as a
guest of the Columbia Graduate School of
Journalism this semester where he's been
meeting with students and faculty to
deepen our understanding
ending of South Asia his newest book
just came out this week in Pakistan on
the brink he examines the many errors of
judgment and understanding that had
beset the major players in this area
from the men who run Pakistan's ISI to
the State and Defense officials in the
bush in the Obama administration's we
would also like to welcome Steve Cole
who's pulitzer-winning book ghost wars
did so much to inform us of the complex
history of the CIA Afghanistan and bin
Laden's several years after the 911
attacks Steve a longtime correspondent
and a senior editor at The Washington
Post now serves as president of the New
America Foundation and his writer for
The New Yorker with no more remarks I'm
very pleased to welcome Ahmed and Steve
to the podium tonight thank you very
much
great well thank you very much for that
introduction thank you all for being
here welcome our plan tonight we've got
about an hour together we've got some
very bright television lights that may
interfere with my ability to see you
when your time comes but our plan is
that Amin and I will talk for about 25
minutes or half an hour so i'll ask him
some questions and then at a certain
stage i'll ask you to present your own
questions there is that microphone right
there in the aisle with that you can
line up behind and there may also be
someone roving for those of you who are
on the edges and such just do please
identify yourself and keep it brief
there's no doubt that there's going to
be many more of you who want to
participate then we'll have time for
Thank You almond for inviting me to be
with you tonight and congratulations on
this book which if that's a camera I'm
going to point it at it this is really
the third as you say you use the word
trilogy and I'm I think I recognize that
kind of self-consciousness and the work
that you've been doing about between
hard covers about this central subject
from the Taliban to descent into chaos
the great and authoritative book that
you produced after the September 11th
attacks and now this is a kind of book
end and as you say in the introduction
this is a little more meditative and a
little more forward-looking and a little
more focused on the issues that bedevil
Pakistanis Afghans and Americans in
common and so I think that's a terrific
basis for our conversation I first went
out to the region in 1989 as a green
correspondent for The Washington Post
and every time I came through lahore
hamed's house was a place to be educated
and that's still the case all these
years later so I feel like we're having
the same conversation we had all that
time ago and of course the first
question everyone arrives in Lahore to
ask you is what is the nature of the
crisis in Pakistan this month and your
Pakistan is on the brink but it's on
it's always on the brink of something
and
I I wonder you know there is a kind of
an accumulation as you point out in some
of these essays about the failures of
the military to come to terms with the
true nature of Pakistan's national
security the failures of Education the
rise of radicalism but thinking in the
long arc that you've been writing how
serious what is the nature of the crisis
today how is it different from other
periods of crisis as you chronicled and
live through well thank you Steve and
thank you very much for coming and thank
all of you for coming and I thank
Columbia University for inviting me to
be here for this semester very very kind
everyone connected with the School of
Journalism I think the essential problem
Steve is that we we never grew up after
the Cold War ended you know the the
Pakistani elite which is the military
and the civilian elite never realized at
the end of the Cold War meant that you
could no longer basically and certainly
911 only reinforced that that you could
no longer keep extreme Islamic
extremists as a front line against India
or to use in Afghanistan that you could
not have a foreign policy that was based
solely on trying to develop scare
tactics you know in the region that you
know you you need a trade and economic
advancement and you know all the rest of
it and for that you needed the
neighboring countries to be part of a
solution and and and and lastly you you
needed to break the dependence that you
had on the United States during the Cold
War and you needed to develop your own
economy and society and all the rest of
it and essentially I think the struggle
you know after 1989 for the last 20
years has been trying to alert the
Pakistani elite that look you essential
the essentials of foreign policy that
you have pursued since 1947 no longer
work and I think that is the essence of
a crisis I mean most most countries have
a foreign policy that reflects domestic
politics and domestic developments and
all the rest of it we have a country
where domestic where foreign policy sets
the tone of domestic development so for
example we have nuclear weapons but we
have no education or we have no health
care we can't take we can't take care of
our own public the last line in the book
I say you know the essential factor is
that the Pakistani elite has not
fulfilled its essential task which was
to take care of the Pakistani people and
and and that's where you know crisis
after crisis come so but how how healthy
or unhealthy today is civilian politics
and civil society led pressure in
Pakistan how are we on the outside to
understand where the PPP government
stands we may have an election later
this year or next year where that would
mark the first peaceful hand off of an
elected civilian government to another
the lawyers movement to court civil
society activism and in at least some of
the urban area seems to be rising to
some extent certainly compared to the
dark days a couple of days ago but is
there there there is there enough of a
an opposition to the military military's
influence to make a difference well you
know there's no doubt that especially
the domestic political crisis in the
last year has been generated by the
Supreme Court and the military going for
the government basically tried to topple
the government without wanting to launch
a coup as is the usual norm for the
military in Pakistan but you know at the
same time the crisis has been
perpetrated also by the civilian
government of the People's Party because
it has been so inept it has been
extremely corrupt it's developed a
terrible reputation and it's done very
little you know for the people so you
have this double whammy of you know a
military that really nobody wants and a
military that is perhaps much weaker
than it was before because there's now a
much greater public resistance to a coup
and to military rules and there perhaps
ever was before in Pakistan and the
military is deeply aware of this i think
but at the same time you have a very
corrupt and inept government
which has not been able to deliver the
goods and I do hope as you say that
there will be an election you know a bad
incompetent corrupt democracy is still
better than military rule because
military rule has led us into four times
into a cul-de-sac you know where we have
to reinvent the wheel and reinvent the
wheel of democracy every few every
decade the military rule last for ten
years and then suddenly you know it
collapses because of some reason or the
other and we have to reinvent democracy
again I so I hope that this election
this government will probably lose the
election there will be another
complicated coalition government I hope
that this will be then sustainable and
hopefully the next government and the
government after that as long as there's
no military intervention will be better
and and i think the rise of civil
society has been very important but
civil society is also very divided
there's a very a very determined right
wing extremist civil society that is
islamist anti-western anti-democracy and
there's also a very there's a liberal
civil society which wants democracy and
good governance and you know for the
military to go back to the barracks and
you know all the rest of it so civil
societies is also very polarized right
now in pakistan we I know we want to
jump in and talk to half gana Stan but
you mentioned that the military does not
seem to be in a position to be able to
intervene now it's certainly not one of
those moments of kind of rescue
narrative where the body politics is
wishing for military intervention to the
contrary if they did intervene they'd
probably face stiff resistance why well
I think the Musharraf era people are
seeing you know the record of the
Musharraf era the getting bogged down in
Afghanistan hosting the Taliban allowing
the the the growth and but the birth and
growth of the Pakistani Taliban the
failure to really invest in Pakistan's
economy even though we were getting you
know two to three billion dollars a year
from the Americans we got a huge debt
write-offs after nine eleven etc there
was just no investment in
country and in the people education
level is after 10 years of Musharraf's
rule was the same so I think that's part
of it but also you know I think if you
if you look at it the every coup in
Pakistan has been welcomed by Brian
large by the majority of the population
the army knows perfectly well that this
time round half the population would be
completely against any kind of military
rule and perhaps there would only be a
very small fringe of right-wing
religious parties and right-wing sort of
you know nutters basically who would
back a military coup and of course a
military coup would be disastrous I'm in
the 21st century I mean a you know a
country of 180 million people should not
be having military coups they you know
they should be allowing democracy to
progress but the the the essential
factor is still the foreign policies in
the hands of the military and unless the
military learns and is desires a change
where it makes friends with neighboring
states it builds up trade and the
economy etc and concentrates on its on
Pakistan's own internal situation rather
than having these adventures in
Afghanistan adventures in Kashmir then
you know we're not going to change no
civilian government can change the
military's foreign policy except the
military itself one of the neighbors
that the military would have to come to
terms win of course is Afghanistan which
has been a problematic neighbor since
1979 or earlier and I wanted to ask you
just your impressions of how severe and
worrisome the patterns of instability
emerging in Afghanistan are and your
judgment now you've witnessed Afghan
government's unravel at multiple
intervals for 30 years that headlines
feel very discouraging because of these
horrifying incidents but when you talk
to President Karzai are people around
him and you think about the political
forces and compacts that are holding
cobbled together
now what's your reading are they are
they stable with can they withstand the
pressures that are being placed upon
them over the next year or two at least
I think the situation in Afghanistan is
now very very fragile and the government
is very vulnerable and the the essential
you know three four months ago what
people were talking about and orderly
withdrawal of Western forces NATO and US
forces you know really may not be
possible now I you know I think that
there are several reasons for this I you
know this was gone on far too long it's
ten years over ten years the longest war
the Americans have ever fought and and I
you know what we are seeing in these
signs of you know this killing of the
Afghan civilians the burning of the
Koran set cetera I mean you know you may
be witnessing the start of a serious
deterioration of discipline and morale
in the US military which is not
surprising given you know these tours of
duty and its etc secondly I think the
the real pursuit at this stage should be
a political strategy to bring the war to
an end America cannot leave Afghanistan
and leave behind a civil war going on
and expected this Afghan army which it
has trained in which it has poured
billions of dollars into will somehow
hold the line and be able to fight as
well as the Americans have or or or
resist the Taliban so essentially what
is needed is a political strategy which
has started but it's it's it's going in
fits and starts its be going far too
slowly and part of the reason is that
their divisions in Washington about that
but within the administration as to
whether we sure whether the Americans
should pursue a faster track negotiation
with the Taliban or slower track and the
military still has to be fully brought
on board with this idea of a negotiated
settlement but you know I think two
things are needed essentially for as far
as the Western intervention is concerned
the need for an orderly withdrawal not a
withdrawal way you're sort of having to
fire you know behind your shoulder as
you retreat as you would draw and
secondly to leave behind an end to this
civil war that is going on in
on some kind of ceasefire some kind of
political negotiation between the
Taliban and the Afghan government now
that's one thing but on the other hand
you've got a government that is very
very unstable it's facing a lot of
opposition from anti-taliban militias
and warlords in the north of the country
who don't want to dialogue with the
Taliban there's rising anti-americanism
there's of course the continued bane of
corruption and incompetents by the
government but I think even more
critical than anything else right now is
the failure of the West who have built
or have built some kind of indigenous
economy in Afghanistan because what's
going to happen after the withdrawal is
that the economy is totally dependent on
the Western intervention I mean the tens
of thousands of afghans are needed to
service 150,000 troops that that that
are there and the moment these troops
leave what do these Afghans do and and
these Afghans by the way are educated
they speak English they are part of the
pro-democracy Pro Western kind of new
Afghan elite that is arisen within the
last 10 years and these guys are all
going to be jobless and they're going to
be looking for ways to leave the country
not to stay and and so there's a
domestic crisis there is a an American
strategic crisis and finally there's the
crisis of the region and the neighbors
Iran Pakistan Russia and Central Asia
India how will these countries you know
deal with an American withdrawal and
when you talk about political strategy
obviously one element of that that you
referred to his direct talks with the
Taliban and there's quite a strong
chapter in this book Pakistan on the
brink about the history of these
negotiations really very revealing and
authoritative and I wonder you know
you've been watching the Taliban from
their birth you wrote the first and
definitive book about them in the 1990s
you obviously favor the negotiations
with them now and believe that they
could produce a reduction in violence
that could use the American withdrawal
and make it less likely that a terrible
civil war is left behind
but what would you say it's realistic to
hope or expect that the Taliban would
accept given that they are a declared
revolutionary movement there an islamic
emirate in exile they believe the
government that they had was improperly
taken from them by foreigners what kind
of an outcome at least an interim
outcome of negotiations do you think
it's realistic to have for now I i think
the Taliban are equally exhausted they
suffered enormous losses also they are
fed up of living in exile in Pakistan
and being manipulated by Pakistani
intelligence they want their their
Afghan they want to go home you know to
that country and and and get it you know
they consider a longer period living in
pacsun almost a trap and and and at the
same time I mean we have seen some
moderation in in their views I mean they
are not anti you know girls education
now they have condemned al-qaeda as
strongly as they can without without an
actual settlement so what I see is a
process that really should be stepped up
now a series of trust building
confidence building measures between the
US and the Taliban which quickly have to
become military trust building in other
words the Taliban would have to reduce
their military activities in exchange
for the u.s. to do the same maybe not
all at once maybe you know province by
province or for a period you know the US
will say well we'll stop nitrates you
know into arresting and capturing
Taliban if you stop assassinating
government officials or stop these mine
mine warfare stop something else and
this could then be extended into both
sides would be testing each other to see
how genuine the other side is on in this
field and then you would have to then
hopefully once you could establish a
reduction in the violence I I don't say
ceasefire but a reduction in the
violence then you would involve the
Afghan government and try and start
political negotiations which would have
to be between the Afghan government and
the Taliban
you know I don't see this as impossible
I I remember very well the Soviets I
spent time which I would not say the
foreign minister at that time the
Soviets were desperate in for a
political settlement with the Mujahideen
at that time as they withdrew out of
Afghanistan and a lot of the Mujahideen
actually wanted a political settlement
they didn't have the same problem they
were fed up with being in Pakistan they
were fed up of being manipulated by the
CIA and the ISI all these other
organizations they wanted to go home and
what happened was of course at the CIA
and Park stands military both of them
did not favor a political settlement
they wanted to see the actual defeat of
the Communists so we're almost in you
know in a you know at I mean having seen
that whole process unravel and the
Soviets are having to get out without a
political settlement and then of course
the civil war starts in Afghanistan you
know in 1989-90 I I have you know I'm
deeply deeply pessimistic I've seen one
unraveling of a superpower involvement
in Afghanistan one failure to have a
political settlement or to be able to
put together a political settlement I
hope that the Americans don't make the
same mistake that that the Soviets did I
I hope they learn they learn something
from the Soviet experience that you know
you need to end this war before you
leave the Taliban have now issued a
statement suspending the talks I don't
know how seriously you take that is that
just negotiating and then another
element of this is that the Taliban
themselves seem to want to talk to the
Americans because there are the
foreigners and the fielded army that
they can test and they're less
interested in talking to President
Karzai but as you were just outlining
what the opportunity here is you were
making the point that it's an intra
Afghan negotiation that would ultimately
reduce violence in any sustainable way
so a how serious is this breach and it
talks so far as you can tell and be
where does President Karzai fit in this
picture given that he has felt annoyed
with the Americans leaving him out of
these talks and also it
least in theory in 2014 he's meant to
leave office and see a successor come in
well look I you know they've been three
incidents of involving American forces
the American soldiers urinating on the
dead bodies of Taliban the burning of
the Koran and this recent incident Orton
or each one of these incidents could
have led to the Taliban suspending talks
but they didn't and I think that was a
very you know it is a very pointed thing
that the Taliban did they kept the talks
moving I mean even through this last
couple of months of these incidents
happening they condemned the incidence
of course and were very brutal and said
you know we behead the Americans and we
will kill them if we see them in all the
necessary but they did not suspend at
all now they have suspended the talks
and that has a lot to do with the
slowness of the Obama administration in
really responding to the first
confidence-building measure which has
been this exchange of prisoners
essentially between the Taliban and the
Americans and this has been pending for
the last three or four months and there
doesn't seem to be very much progress i
hope that there will be progress on this
in the next few weeks and I I do believe
that the Taliban will then resume talks
again because you know the need to talk
the Americans obviously is they have to
deal with the military situation first
in Afghanistan and if there's no point
in talking to Karzai about the military
situation because he's not in control of
the military situation the Americans are
so Karzai comes in at a later stage
whether you actually are talking about a
some kind of sharing of power in Kabul
between cars and the Taliban so I'm
confidence that the talks will you know
will resume quite soon and you know yes
I mean the the very big issue of is
President Karzai he has been very
erratic and he's been very frustrated by
by by the Americans and by the frankly
the Erastus ISM of the obvi of
Washington which has been no less than
you know his errata season I mean
especially over the last few months and
as I say this continued Division in the
American administration over whether to
talk
not to talk you know whether to fight
not to fight what to do etc but he he's
only allowed two terms as president he
finishes his term in 2014 now of course
do you think you'll live I I really
can't say I mean I hope he does I hope
he does and certainly if I was president
cuz I would be telling him that you
should from now be preparing to leave
and anoint someone who you would like to
see succeed you and prepare the ground
for that and give Afghan people the
confidence that you will be leaving
there will be a free and fair election
or a better election that was held last
time in 2014 and and also this would I
you know to a large extent you know
gratify the international community and
encourage the international community to
continue giving aid to you because at
the moment frankly I mean if I you know
the mood in Europe right now and I think
I haven't been Washington yet but I mean
even there would be I mean nobody wants
to help Afghanistan in real terms beyond
2014 and of course Afghanistan is going
to need large quantities of aid for many
years to come if for nothing else than
to sustain the army so we you know cuz I
has to take certain steps for his
country and to keep the international
community on board and and certainly
this is not going to be done if he
insists that oh no I'm indispensable I
will delay the elections or I will stand
for a third term I think this would be a
huge huge mistake and we could really
bring the whole got his whole government
crumbling down and perhaps forced the
Taliban to do nothing else except to
take carbon now the subtitle of the book
is the future of America Pakistan and
Afghanistan and you have a number of
sort of interlinked essays towards the
back of the book that are all very
strong and it seemed if I read them
right that one of your themes was that
you feel that the American design the
strategic design that the United States
has looking forward
or Afghanistan ax Stan its relations
with its role in Pakistan remains a
muddle now we were talking before I was
on a call a background call that the
White House put on for you know Afghan
watchers today to talk about how things
are going and the good news is things
are going really really well apparently
everything is right on track there's not
a there's not a single aspect of the
plan that is in trouble so that gives us
some time to think about the design that
you have in mind and I wonder really
what you mean when you say that the
United States needs to clarify or
improve in effect its strategic vision
for the region after 2014 what are the
what are the missing elements of that
what are the sources of confusion that
are really making things worse now well
I think the first thing is that there
has to be a United us plan you can't
have a plan that you know one plan by
the Pentagon one plan by the State
Department you have to have a united
plan and you know they're there has to
be the US has to help broker an internal
settlement and a regional settlement now
this is very difficult because you have
no relations with Iran and of course
relations with Iran a very bad because
of the nuclear situation and right now
today as of today you for the last four
months you had no speaking relationship
with Pakistan either I hope that will be
rectified very soon but it's at the
moment it's a complete dead end so that
that there has to be unity on you know
these two things seeking an internal
settlement and I you know I I've
supported a lot of the things President
Obama has done you know the surge was
matched the military surge was matched
by a civilian surge more money for
development etc but it couldn't take off
because you know the fighting
intensified but what I one of what my
criticism of this administration has
been that they have pursued many
different initiatives none of them fully
none of them with consistency you know
none of them to the end I mean what
happened to for example the whole
counterinsurgency doctrine that
General Petraeus introduced in
Afghanistan which was you know we're
fighting to protect the people and to
build these enclaves in the people you
know that's almost disappeared from the
you know from the reports or from
anything that the administration says
again this the the the failure in the
last three to four years to be aware
that you know the Afghans need an
economy to keep this country going and
and the failure really to build an
indigenous economy that is not dependent
on just foreign forces so I think you
know and I think you know the biggest
problem is right now in the united
states that the as a result of two you
know bush presidencies and two wars that
you forge and God forbid that there
might be a third war with Iran but you
know the military has exerted enormous
political pressure on the seville
administration it's quite a lot of
people are Costanzi say it's quite
similar to the situation in pakistan
that you have an overwhelming military
you know basically who dictate and push
through their concept of foreign policy
and invariably it's to do with force of
arms victory you know we will not accept
being driven out by the taliban and that
kind of thing now i think that is
changing because you know i mean i hope
it is changing and certainly after these
incidents it needs to be changed but i
think obama president obama has been
trapped in this in this outcome which is
not a result of his policies so much as
much as a result of President Bush's
policies of having fought two wars and
and quite frankly right now many you
know many Muslims around the world are
fearing that if the United States having
attacked two Muslim countries in the
last ten years if it attacks a third in
other words Iran there is no saying what
chaos and confusion could ensure for
American foreign policy in the broader
Muslim world it could completely
undermine the Arab Spring it could you
know it could undermine all the
Democratic aspirations that are going on
right now in the Middle East it could
completely undermine Pakistan and
Afghanistan
and and and and you know several other
countries along the way and I just hope
that you know this doesn't happen that
there is some settlement with Iran so I
want to in a moment invite the audience
to join us and so those of you who have
questions if you'd like to start lining
up at the microphone you can do that I
have one more just to complete the loop
on this if the problem with American
policy or the design of American policy
in Afghanistan as you were just saying
is part that that it's fight and talk
simultaneously which seemed not always
to join together as a unified approach
very well in Pakistan tonight the
Parliament is going to start a debate
about the future from Pakistan
perspective of relations with the United
States the US is in you know multiple
conversations in Washington as i'm sure
you'll join when you get there about
whether the relationship between the
United States and Pakistan should be
redesigned in some way reset redefined
what is a sustainable basis a mutually
sustainable basis for relations civil
civilian-led relations between the
United States and Pakistan over the next
20 years what should be the basis for a
rear thinking of that relationship well
i think i think you know from the
american side the Pakistanis need to be
taken into confidence about the these
talks and they need to be bought in at
some level with these talks with the
Taliban the more that they're kept out
the more angry and son sidelined the
military and the intelligence will feel
and and the more resentment will build
up there inside the country propagated
you know by the intelligence services
you know that the Americans are trying
to cut a separate deal without Pakistan
now so I think you know that's the first
thing I think I think the second thing
really is that yes the relationship is
going to be entirely reset there's no
doubt in my mind and there will be a
restrictions placed on the kind of
freedom that the US intelligence and the
drone attacks and every and the US had
during the Bush administration I mean
when literally
hundreds if not thousands of contractors
and CIA were operating in Pakistan etc
well I really think that what the US has
to do now you know a lot of this bad
blood that was created between the US
military and the backs on military was a
result of what was felt is us pressure
on the Pakistani military to do this or
that now I think what what long-term
your strategy should be is you know how
does the US helped change without
putting you know day-to-day daily
pressure go after this terrorist go
after that Terrace forget the
intelligence relationship if that is not
going to be restored in the way it
existed before forget about it you don't
need American generals going to
Islamabad saying you know go after the
economy network go after this little
what you need is Americans of civilian
support basically for a shift in
Pakistan strategic dimensions and you
need a real strategic dialogue with
Pakistan as to how far Pakistan is
willing to shift its foreign policy you
know what I've been talking about and
what the u.s. can do to help not the US
dictating what parks aren't you do but
how the US can help economically
building you know improving relations
with India trade links energy
electricity etc and how the US can also
help in galvanizing the international
community to make sure that Afghanistan
and Pakistan remain on the agenda
despite the international recession and
the you know the economic collapse in
Europe and you know all the rest of it
so I think you know the u.s. also needs
to shift towards a longer view and a
more strategic view about not wanting a
day to day result you know in the tribal
areas about so-and-so chairs but but but
let me having said that I I you know as
you will read in this book I'm extremely
critical of Pakistan's continued desire
to keep the Taliban the Afghan Taliban
for as long as possible on Pakistani
soil allow them to continue fighting I
think Pakistan should give a deadline
or at least when once the relationship
with the u.s. resumes give a deadline to
the Afghan Taliban you have to leave
this country in six months or a year you
have to settle your problems with the
American settle your problems with
Karzai and leave well you know we we are
not going to sustain you for any longer
I think that that kind of step would win
enormous international support for
Pakistan but you know that would
obviously mean a complete you know you
turn as far as our foreign policy is
concerned well let me invite the
audience I can't really tell in this
glare whether someone is standing at the
microphone or approaching it so please
do identify yourself and and and ask a
direct question if you will my name is
Roy Abdi I'm a student at the law school
next door and my question is how do you
think the Pakistani public's mood would
react to a change either in the current
administration or a future one if the
focus moved away from external threats
like with India or the Afghan Taliban
and move towards the economy in other
words is there is there a sort of point
of pride in the Pakistani public and
that is related to holding on to Kashmir
or or the Afghan Taliban or other
external influences that maybe would be
an internal reason that the government
keeps these militaristic options on the
table look I mean I mean there's no
doubt that there is very strong
anti-americanism right now in in
Pakistan but I really believe that
people I mean this could change and
people really want to live normal lives
and what I said you know earlier about
the military being unsure of itself the
military not being able to launch a coup
not because you know it suddenly changed
but because it's it knows that half the
population would not support it I think
you know most parks Danny's want to as
you know see prosperity education
economic development and they have not
been you know they have not been
provided that in in in
60 so many years so I think there's a
and certainly now there's a huge change
towards India amongst the population
perhaps not with the army so much the
business community wants to do business
with India they want investment from
India they were a trade with India now
obviously you've got to settle your
differences with India in order for that
job to happen and I think you know the
really sure the Pakistan is a you know
the geography of Pakistan should have
been you know is at the center of all
these trade links Iran to India Central
Asia to the Gulf Pakistan could be a
land bridge for enormous economic
productivity in this region and it has
not given itself the opportunity to do
so it needs to do so and I think the
public would really support that thank
you hi my name is Veronica agarwal i'm a
senior in the college my question is
twofold first of all I want to go back
to the warlord so if you look at a time
muhammad nor for example when you look
at the success he's had in the bulk
province I guess my question is do you
see Karzai and cooperation with the
northern warlords as potentially being a
viable political option could they
perhaps aid in anti-taliban ISM my
second question is you kept stressing
that there's an importance to build a
domestic economy but do you have
specific I guess recommendations or
ideas as to how to do that given that
for example the climate the environment
is very arid trade would be dependent on
international relations which of course
are in a very tenuous position right now
so kind of what do you see as concrete
steps to doing that so for the Afghan
Afghan about for Afghanistan
yeah well look I mean it's fine you know
Carla is concerned I hope that you won't
be there in twenty fourteen iop will
step down and that I I think it's very
critical that Afghanistan does have a
new leadership who who can bridge the
gap the ethnic divide the ethnic divide
is now very serious in Afghanistan and
especially over the store over this
whole dialogue with the Taliban and you
need a new face a new figure with
endorsement from cars a with endorsement
from the west from the Americans etc you
need a new political dispensation in
Kabul and I hope that you know that will
happen in
2014 as far as the economy is concerned
look I mean even for example right now
the the electricity in northern
Afghanistan is being provided from
Central Asia the electricity in western
Afghanistan is being provided by Iran
now this is all without you know these
are local warlords who have concocted
their own deals with with the
neighboring countries and in fact the
electricity that comes to Kabul is
coming from Uzbekistan you know so you
you already have the basis for what
Afghanistan would be best at also as a
land bridge you know this is a
landlocked country it's got six
neighbors and all these neighbors want
to trade with each other by road by rail
except they're blocked because there's a
war going on in Afghanistan if that war
ends you could make a lot of money from
being this land bridge there's you know
the whole idea of pipelines oil and gas
coming from Central Asia feeding energy
starved Afghanistan Pakistan India and
then you know trade with the Gulf etc so
that would be the first thing and the
second thing is you know investment in
agriculture Afghanistan remains despite
you know a very difficult terrain only
twelve percent of Afghan territory is
actually arable but you know in the
1970s they had that they fed themselves
they had a small agricultural surplus
that they exported we haven't even been
able to restore the state of the economy
in 1978 you know before the communist
coup took place so and and and that was
heavily dependent on agriculture
obviously today you can do wondrous
things you know canning and freezing and
shipping and you know all this kind of
stuff I mean you know the fruits of
Afghanistan in the 70s was sold in India
and Pakistan in Iran and in the Gulf
today doing that would be ten times
easier than what it was in the 70s
because of transport Nordic etc so I
think there's an enormous potential it
just has not been developed or built up
unfortunate
and what role do you see the Warlord's
playing going forward the northern
warlords in Afghanistan well I hope that
if there's a new political leadership
they will cooperate and I think if
there's progress in the talks of the
Taliban if the Americans and the Taliban
show progress I think the mood can shift
very rapidly because you know at the end
of the day even the northern warlords do
not want another Civil War they don't
want to go and fight again yeah just to
follow up on that I mean we throw that
term around warlords it's not really
clear who deserves it and who doesn't it
here in the United States or in
Afghanistan and but when you talk about
a new political dispensation in 2014 a
world after Karzai it's so critical and
you say the next leader would need to
hold the confidence of non Taliban
Pashtuns not be anathema to the Taliban
presumably have hold the confidence of
the international community and not
ignite a civil war by northern groups
that are fearful of Taliban hegemony so
that's that's a heck of a search
committee task that's being it so
without you if you want to name names i
welcome you but but who where is that
leader going to come from in Afghanistan
today and also Karzai's going to have to
anoint them and and he's going to his
family and his networks are going to
have to have confidence he's not going
to throw them all in front of the ICC
yeah so so where does this person come
from well look I mean you know there
have been some very good ministers in
the Afghan government over the last ten
years unfortunately all of them have
been thrown out by cars I you know
partly because they were too competent
they were more educated than he was if
they had better ideas in he had now you
know I don't name names but I mean I
think there were there were many
Pashtuns who have been thrown out who
could play a very important role in the
next government and there are people
there moderates in the non Pashtuns in
the North who could also hopefully form
some kind of working coalition but I
think a lot of this will depend on how
the talks with the Taliban progress and
how these are conducted by the Americans
and buy cars I because there's one
perception at one conspiracy theory in
Kabul which is essentially this is a
deal that the Karzai family is
with the Taliban they're going to have a
deal with the Taliban to preserve their
wealth and the corruption with all the
rest of it and they'll give up the
Taliban a seat at the table in the
government and this doesn't involve the
rest of Afghanistan the rest of the
ethnic groups or anything like that now
so far frankly I mean Karzai has not
built a consensus in the country for the
talks he has not conducted these talks
in a politically wholesome manner this
needs to change now it's not going to
change by telling him I mean the amount
for the American ambassador to go up and
say you know you got to change and bring
in all these northerners and the non
Pashtuns he's not going to do it he's
going to change only if there's progress
on the ground between the Americans and
the Taliban if he sees the inevitability
of a settlement and and and a settlement
that will have to be fair and square for
all of God's not just for his family or
for his network as you said then you
know you know I think I think it can
happen i agree with you i mean you've
given the present state of affairs of
the American deployment in Afghanistan
and given the wishful thinking in the
White House as you described it that
everything is hunky-dory and fine where
exactly the opposite is probably true
you know it does look a long haul but
you know I I'm I look I I wouldn't have
been covered Afghanistan for 32 years if
I wasn't an optimist every I mean you
know every time you turn your head
around you know new civil war breaks out
and add you tell my god you know and you
thought well the Soviets left is going
to be this big deal a big step of month
you know peace will come and you know it
cetera et cetera and you know within 24
hours a new civil war break I mean I've
seen this happen too many times you know
but I still remain an optimist I remain
an optimist because I really believe
that the Afghan people have something in
them that really wants you know a piece
and and and the settlement ordinary
Afghan people i don't mean those who've
been cashing in on you know corruption
and all the rest of it yeah look what
put up with from us for the last 10
years as evidence of your hypothesis
yeah yes I have two questions firstly
could you share your opinion on how with
a Honda band Pakistan Taliban how
distinct are they added to both the two
groups with the same ideologies are the
different you mentioned earlier on in
the evening that you thought that the
Afghan Taliban were moving away from the
antique female education stance whereas
the Pakistani Taliban is still blowing
up schools in North Shara and Peshawar
and whatnot so as you share your opinion
on whether these two groups are distinct
and what makes them so and the second
question is a sort of a follow-up
question is that what would it take for
the Pakistani Taliban to achieve some
sort of settlement with the Pakistani
government which would allow the
civilian democracy in Pakistan to
survive in a sustainable fashion other
than xiomy are the regulations of three
years ago so just for the sake of those
who may not know the nuances could you
also just start by giving a quick
thumbnail of who the Pakistani Taliban
are today and why they're distinct from
the Afghan Taliban well the Pakistani
Taliban initially arose in the Pashtun
border regions between Afghanistan and
Pakistan as a result of the Afghan
Taliban presence and Al Qaeda's presence
in the border regions after 2001 because
all of al Qaeda and the Afghan Taliban
who survived the American invasion fled
into Pakistan then they set up shop
there they had a lot of money etc and
they cultivated militancy in amongst the
Pakistani tribes there and this
militancy then expanded and developed
and and then started not just helping
the war in Afghanistan but also taking
on the Pakistan Army now in answer to
your question I think the Afghan Taliban
in the Pakistani Taliban are very
distinct entities the Pakistani Taliban
is aims at toppling still aims at
toppling the central government and
introducing shallowford they you know
they want to go back to old Islamic
times and and and the real difference is
that they have in very close links to
al-qaeda and they also have the links of
all the militant groups
operations in Pakistan against India and
these groups who are basically in Punjab
province many of these fighters form the
bulk now of what we call the Pakistani
Taliban so the Pakistani Taliban
involves groups from now from all over
the country which is why they pose a
much greater threat than ever before you
know Tupac son and as I said I think the
Afghan Taliban are slowly moderating
their positions on various things like
you mentioned you know they don't burn
for the last year or so as far as i know
the Afghan Taliban have been banned from
burning girls schools or and they allow
girls education the Pakistani Taliban
goat and they don't allow any kind of
education except their own kind of
education so you know they're there is
now how would the Pakistani Taliban come
to come to rest well look the Pakistani
Taliban logic is that we are fighting
the Backson army because there is a
jihad in Afghanistan against the the
infidel Americans we support that jihad
we fight in that jihad and the Pakistan
Army is a stooge of the Americans and is
helping the Americans fight that job
that is why we are fighting thee now if
the Afghan Taliban were to make peace
with Kabul and you know obviously the
whole raison d'etre of job jihad would
disappear and then you know the
Pakistani Taliban what justification
would they have for continuing to attack
the Pakistani Taliban they certainly
would not have any kind of religious
justification at all and I think if
there was a reasonable kind of peace in
Afghanistan the knock-on effect for that
in Pakistan would be enormously
productive you know the Taliban really
would be left without an ideological
base and if the right policies were
pursued by the military and the next
civilian government then you know I i
think the Pakistani Taliban can be
bought to rest but we have to deal also
with these militant groups have been
fighting against India because they
still pose an enormous threat to the
stability of Pakistan there are large
numbers
and they have been supported by the
military and the intelligence services
for a long period of time and and that
status quo has to be broken by you know
by the government not by attacking them
or killing them or anything else but by
trying to bring them into the system and
their many ways that that kind of
reconciliation can work thank you hi my
name is Rahul I'm a student at the
journalism school two questions to you
mr. Rashid the first one is on what
happened in Delhi with Salman Rushdie
and Imran Khan and I'd like to know your
opinion on what this man is all about
what Imran Khan is all about what is his
politics to do you think by not going to
India he's got he's going to get the
mula vote has he struck a deal with the
army etc etc one the second question
relates to you know you have you through
a slight dig at the Pakistani elite now
why is the Pakistani le do you think why
has it been so apathetic for so long and
what makes the Pakistani elite this
strange inert creature you think it is
yeah thank you well look I know you have
to explain what the well is a dust-up
was probably not everyone here was
following it online imran fan of course
is the former cricket star and
charitable you know he's he set up
hospitals etc is now he's launched
himself into politics and his enormous
support from young people who want to
see change and were fed up with the
existing two major political parties and
that's quite understandable and and the
dust-up was that both imran and salman
rushdie were invited to delhi for a conf
at a conference and imran refused to go
because he said that salman rushdie you
know has insulted muslims with the with
his book Satanic Verses etc and I don't
want to go on salman rushdie then
responded and said that you know he's a
stooge of the military and he's a stooge
of the mullahs that's why he didn't come
and etc so I mean you know but Alex
that's what look
you know I think it's too early to judge
Imran Khan there's no doubt yeah the man
is very popular and he is trying to
build a political base and but you know
there are some visible signs are a bit
worrisome for example the entire cabinet
and politicians who served with
Musharraf in other words the last
military ruler in Pakistan have joined
imran khan and and and these politicians
many people in parks under would not
move one inch without you know
clarification from the military if it
was okay or not secondly he has had very
close links to Islamic parties the
jamaat-e-islami and many of the
ideologues on the Islamic right and and
he's you know accused liberals of
Pakistan of of undermining him etc but i
still believe it's too early I mean I
think you know we have to have be faced
with an election campaign we have to see
what he's actually offering at the
moment he's offering everything you know
I'll get rid of corruption in 90 days
I'll change the economy in 90 days but
obviously you know that's going to be a
hard sell in an election campaign he has
to become more concrete and more
accurate as to what exactly he's going
to do and who his friends are you know
so I think you know we have to wait and
see yeah so I was I was in Pakistan last
month and spend some time with him and
all i can add is in the Saturday Night
Live phrase he looks marvelous he's
doing he's really is now there's two
people left there's five minutes left so
if the two questioners will break the
pattern of asking two questions each and
ask one question each then we can take
those have ammad respond to them and
then we'll get you out of your own time
so please all right I'll try to make it
quick I am NOT an optimist and my
question is do you think a full-fledged
counterinsurgency program aimed at the
Taliban is necessary to prevent al-qaeda
from attacking the United States and
also necessary to secure the nuclear
weapons
in Pakistan thank you and behind him yes
please yes we lost work with regards to
the nuclear weapons The Atlantic Monthly
ran an article in December essentially
alleging that weaponized materials were
being transported in utility vans
through Islamabad traffic so I'd be
curious to hear your take on that sort
of reporting as far as whether such
sensational reporting affects the
dynamics of the relationship look I mean
you know we know very little about you
know the state of the nuclear weapons we
certainly know that the army controls
them the army remains a disciplined
hierarchical force and you know at the
moment that that discipline and
hierarchy he is holding and you know I
hope it obviously everyone hopes it
continues to hold but the other thing is
that I think there is a a relationship
certainly there was after nine eleven
between bush and the Pakistani military
and probably with this administration as
far as nuclear weapons are concerned I
think you know if there was real concern
I think you know successive
administrations would be going public on
it and would be putting far more
pressure than them than we've seen so I
think you know what I mean as a somebody
who knows very little about you know and
Pakistanis generally don't know very
much about the state of nuclear weapons
I would say if the Americans are not
raising a who are and NATO is also not
raising a a kerfuffle on a daily basis
as it is for example on us pursuing her
Connie or as pursuing gulbuddin
Hekmatyar or anyone else you know there
is you know ten years but i would say a
stable control of the nuclear weapons
because the international community does
not seem overtly wired about it but i
would not be complacent about it and I
as a Pakistani use me you know I as I
said I think we need to change our
foreign policy we need to do all sorts
of things and we need to reconcile with
these militants inside the country we
need to end this insurgency in Pakistan
abide the Pakistani Taliban
on etc etc so it's it's not an easy
issue right away the the second thing is
no I mean look I think al Qaeda has more
or less being decimated the core group
of al-qaeda that existed in Afghanistan
and Pakistan has been more or less
decimated I don't think the Afghan
Taliban certainly they've had a very
close relationship over the years but I
don't think now politically speaking
they want a relationship and they've
certainly done their best I think to
distance themselves from the Taliban
they have categorically said that no
foreign group will ever be allowed to
take up residence in Afghanistan again
you know once there is a political
settlement inside Afghanistan I think
you know that doesn't mean al Qaeda is
gone because of course we've got the you
know the rebirth of al Qaeda in all
sorts of new places that didn't exist
before or at least groups who say that
they're linked to al Qaeda whether it's
Nigeria or Somalia or North Africa or
Yemen and of course you've got the
development of al-qaeda copycats
operating out of Europe and even for the
first time in the United States I mean
you know with the time square bombing
and other individual acts of terrorism
not an organizer but individual acts of
terrorism that have taken place and it
seems that most of these acts of
terrorism now are getting inspiration
not necessarily from the core group
operating in Pakistan or Afghanistan but
operating elsewhere for example the
Yemeni al-qaeda has been much more
influential in recent months so you know
I I don't see that true I think but you
know pakistan needs to sort out its own
problems at its own pace with its own
solutions it certainly doesn't need a
military adventure by the Americans to
come in and tell you know to deal with
this issue militarily or because dealing
with this issue militarily would would
lead to disastrous implications it could
it would certainly divide the country it
could divide the army it could lead to
very catastrophic long-term threats so
Pakistan really needs to sort
out its own problems and and the purpose
of this book simply is to try and
explain you know where in the long term
Pakistan has gone wrong and where where
you know a correction could be made well
it's a purpose fully realized Pakistan
on the brink is what's brought us
together here thanks to Columbia
University thanks to all of you for
participating and i'm at as always it's
just an inspiration to listen to you and
a privilege I think what those of us who
know you in in Lahore perhaps take for
granted that people here should
understand is that your work is not only
brilliant and persistent and careful and
clear in all the ways that your talk
today has been but it really is also an
active personal courage you're under
direct threat periodically in the
setting where you work you have stayed
year after year you have gone back to
puck to Afghanistan year after year and
you you really have our admiration for
for the whole of it and also for your
ability to use the words hoo-hah and
kerfuffle in the same sentence so I
challenge any speaker at Columbia
University to match that I thank you all
very much and good night
you